Israel has been
known as the stable democracy
in the Middle East.
It has also been home to the growing
and extremely important global
tech sector.
Many of the technologies
that we use today came from Israel,
which is why the latest
protests in the street
over the new judicial reforms
is so serious.
In many cases, people are saying
that the very fabric of the country
is at stake.
Two months of protests on the streets
of Israel
with the demonstrators
coming from
all corners of Israeli society
and as a growing fear.
Democratic values are under threat.
An unprecedented overhaul
of the Israeli legal system
could dramatically shrink
the powers of the Supreme Court
and hand sweeping new authority
to the Knesset.
Israel's parliament
sets out to limit York
The new rules would prevent
the Supreme Court
justices from striking down legislation
passed by lawmakers.
The rules would change the way
judges are selected,
giving more power to politicians.
And it would allow for a simple majority
in the Knesset to overturn rulings
from the court
Bibi Miller, she said.
Behind the plan
is a new ultra right coalition government
led by longstanding
prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu.
The prime minister has tried to frame
this plan
as mere constitutional housekeeping,
making things better Israel's long
standing commitment to liberal values
and the rule of law
has helped
the country attract
many billions of dollars of investment
from Western companies.
The country's far right finance minister
says that judicial reforms
will attract even more investment.
However,
one of Israel's former
central bank
governors strongly disagrees
with that proposal.
I look at Poland, I look at Hungary,
I look much more extreme.
Turkey everywhere.
Well, the judicial system has weakened
economic performance has weakened
foreign investment as decline.
Doubts about Israel's economic future
appear to be growing.
The shekel has already fallen sharply
as credit agencies
warn Israel's rating could suffer.
And leaders
in the tech sector
fear investment could move elsewhere.
Despite all this opposition,
the government here is forging ahead
and hoping to pass the new laws
by Passover next month.
Now to
Israel's current central bank governor,
who tells me that the independence
of the judiciary
is imperative and essential.
I spoke to Governor Amir Yaron
because, of course,
if judicial independence is up for grabs,
then I of course, I wanted to know
whether central bank independence
would also be up for grabs.
The governor has been
critical of the reforms
and he hasn't changed his views.
Right now,
the changes in the judicial reform
could weaken some of this independence.
Moreover,
the process itself is hasty one,
and that does not have a wide agreement
in the public. Do you fear?
And of course, on this program tonight,
we will hear investors
in the tech industry,
which is a huge part of the economy here,
basically saying we will withdraw.
We will disinvest.
We have seen
some high tech leaders
and industry leaders
telling us that maybe investment firms
won't come in
and some of them are even talking that
they might take their business elsewhere
in the long run.
The implication might be
basically brain drain, etc..
And this is why this
needs to be handled with care.
This has huge implications.
And this is why, again, it's imperative
that we maintain
the strength and independent
of this institution.
And this is done
in a way that is
has a wide acceptance in the public.
And it's a transparent process.
You keep talking about
the institutional aspect
and the independence
of the institutional aspect.
That suggests
to someone like me
you're basically worried you're next.
So do you fear that
your independence is under
could be under threat?
I cannot be clearer than this.
The independence of the governor,
the independence of the central bank
are critical to the economy.
Any country that has tinkered,
let alone weakened,
the independence of the central
bank, has suffered dire
economic consequences.
I believe all our leaders
and decision makers
ultimately understands this and therefore
would not come close
to touching the independence of the bank.
You understand it
or you hope it, Richard.
The proof
in the pudding
is the prime minister himself
and also the finance minister.
Immediately
when these issues came up, stated
very clearly
that only the governor decides
on the interest rates
and the central bank independence
is central bank independence.
Let's talk about the economy.
It's pretty robust.
It's good you're raising rates
Have you revised your terminal rate?
Israel
has had a great economic performance
in the last couple of years.
We've grown 8.6% in 21
and 6.6 and a half percent in 20, 22.
And we're on a way to 3% during 20, 23.
And the hope is to go back to three
and a half percent in 20, 24.
I should give the government
lots of credit.
It just passed a budget
that was moderate, was not expansionary.
Moreover, public wages
were done in in a way
that was also modest and not expansion.
I think what we are seeing
everywhere is the stickiness of inflation
that is especially in services.
So we are determined
absolutely determined
to bring inflation
back down to its target.
And if that means
continuing raising rates
and that is our primary tool
that's what we will do.
The reality of what you have just said
and the sticky notes of inflation.
Are you surprised that central bankers
don't really understand
why they're not seeing a more of
a response?
I think all central banks or many central
banks are facing this stickiness.
It's partly
goes back to the exit of COVID,
to the facts,
to the fact that there were vast fiscal
stimulus in Israel.
It wasn't as big as in the US,
but we have a thriving economy,
partly because of what I said
in the high tech sector
that allows for more consumption
and for more people's spending.
We we're also seeing some shifts
in the labor market, and that means
that it will take a little bit
more pain, probably
in order to bring inflation back down
to its target.
But at what point do you decide, wow,
we're close enough to the target,
we're left with pivot?
Is pivoting dangerous?
I think pivoting is dangerous.
We know
and there is experience in the past
that if you stop too early,
inflation can come back with a vengeance.
And therefore, I predict that
at least around the world,
we will see rates continue to go up
and they will stay up
for quite a bit longer.
Is this the most difficult
of economic scenarios?
Our job is difficult.
It is to manage the economy.
The job
to take inflation down today, it's
it involves pain.
And in Israel,
it involves direct pain
because many of the mortgages
are tied down directly
to the central bank interest rate.
You've got a lot on your plate,
haven't you?
I mean, you really have.
It's it's not easy.
What do you do to switch off
on a personal.
Yeah. Yeah.
Do you switch off?
First of all, this is a 20 47 job.
Richard, just if you look at my terms
so far, I had five elections for
prime ministers,
for finance minister Pandemia.
We had a mini war here.
We, of course,
Ukraine, Russia, inflation.
So the plate is full.
My basically people know
I love to run on the beach
and I invite everyone abroad to come in
and see the beautiful beaches in Israel
with me.
It's Hudachko
who is our correspondent in Israel.
He does when I listen to the governor
and I also think about the other issues,
for example,
the settlements, the violence over that,
the expansion of the Jewish settlements
that dozens of people
who have been killed.
One gets this feeling of a country
almost falling apart.
It is incredible to think of all the
massive fronts
that this country is already facing.
Not only on the internal domestic issues,
but then, of course,
with the Israeli-Palestinian conflict
that's been rearing its head, really.
And I think in any other time period,
what's been happening in the West
Bank, what's been happening with
this deadly violence
would be the top story.
But then at the same time,
you have what's happening
on the streets, these massive protests
and also what's happening
in the international arena.
Keep in mind,
Benjamin Netanyahu has not been invited
to the US or the UAE just yet.
And Saudi and Iran, of course,
which complicates it even more. Exactly.
I mean,
and I think that goes to show you
the sensitive balancing act
that Benjamin
Netanyahu needs to have right now,
because not only is
he facing these international fronts,
but domestically,
he needs to keep these right
wing blocs as part of his coalition
otherwise he's not in power. Okay.
But the question
or the comment I hear most often
is that the tail wagging the dog
that Benjamin
Netanyahu said,
I will control the coalition,
but actually
the coalition is controlling him.
And I think a big test
and that maybe the true test will be
what's going to happen
next week with Ramadan coming,
with Passover coming,
there's a lot of concern
about security issues
specifically in Jerusalem.
I think a lot of eyes
will be on Itamar Ben-gvir,
the minister of national security.
Will he be doing anything
that potentially make
the situation worse?
And will Benjamin need to
now be able to control him?